[Music]
season that's about to kick into high
gear because the Golden Globes are
happening this Sunday I'm so excited I'm
ready let's get into it one of the best
things about the Globes is it brings
together the biggest stars from TV and
the big screen and we're breaking down
what to look for starting with the movie
nominees and the Golden Globe goes to
Emma Stone
can Emma make it two for two
last year's winner for lala land she's
up for Best Actress in a comedy for
playing Billie Jean King in battle of
the sexes more nonsense you spell the
worst gonna be when you lose
Emma's bringing Billie Jean to the red
carpet only fair after the tennis legend
took her to the US Open to have Billie
Jean returned the commentary alright
just parole me me just for you boys come
true Emma Spears competition ladybirds
Saoirse Ronan and Margot Robbie who
somehow got us to root for bad girl
Olympian Tonya Harding I get the sense
that she felt somewhat vindicated that
her side of the story was finally told
do you have the papers not yet the Best
Actor in a Drama race pits the posts are
Tom Hanks against critical favorite Gary
Oldman up for playing Winston Churchill
and don't dismiss Denzel Washington
nominated for playing against his
charismatic screen persona he's awkward
we all are
I enjoyed the opportunity to get to be
that to embrace that Best Actress in a
Drama might be the globe's nail-biter
Jessica Chastain faces Sally Hawkins
Frances McDorman Michelle Williams and
Meryl Streep no matter the outcome Meryl
thinks the winners gonna have a lot to
say right now we're gonna talk about
women from
quite a bit and parity and equal pay can
you guess which movie star has won the
most Golden Globes well I'm pretty sure
all of us can guess this it's Meryl
Streep she's won eight
[Music]
you